you
the blood typing game is an educational
game that teaches students about the
human blood types by administering
virtual blood transfusions to patients
when you receive your patient you need
to discover their blood type before
performing the transfusion first use the
syringe to draw your patient's blood and
deposit it into three test tubes the
test tubes contain three different
reagents with either a B or RH
antibodies the antibodies attached to
antigens on the patient's red blood
cells if they match no agglutination in
test tube a indicates that the patient
does not belong to blood group a
agglutination in test tube B indicates
the patient does belong to blood group B
in test tube Rh the blood is Rh positive
if there is clumping and Rh negative
if there is no clumping we know that
this patient's blood type is b-positive
because clumping occurred in the test
tubes containing B and Rh antibodies
check to see how many bags of blood your
patient needs select the bags of blood
that are compatible with your patients
blood type people can safely receive
blood from the same blood type as our
own but also from some other compatible
blood types this compatible blood chart
shows which Bloods are compatible with
the others our patient can obviously
receive B positive blood but can also
receive B negative
o positive or o negative if you give
your patient the wrong blood type the
red blood cells from the donated blood
will clump which can have fatal
consequences for the patient the blood
typing educational game helps students
understand blood typing through visual
enforcement in this hands-on animated
game it is an excellent tool for
teachers to use in the classroom
the Nobel Prize in medicine was awarded
to Karl Landsteiner in 1930 for his
discovery of ABO human blood groups
later he was also involved in
discovering the Rh blood group system
you